[Music]
now yawn you always have so much going
you're constantly on the road with the
band
you've got the store the record label
the radio program yawn Livan flavored
vodka and now yawn Levon European tools
[Music]
always expanding when I was little boy
in Poland all the times I dreaming of
America your invest have built all my
business you cannot go wrong with this
man he never stops we went in we get the
beach
great Java that learning we did real
good managed today oh nice and thick
nice and thick my favorite size see on
the bus Ronnie mister the wine do you
know why I'm here
yes he's very good investment to help
build Empire oh no no no I'm not here to
invest what you're doing is illegal
as of today yet think of all that money
back to your investors today today are
some other today how I make all this
money we want to invest more in genuine
show gifts but something's going on
no nothing on everything good you do
anything to hurt this family I will
destroy you okay no no no I just need to
fill up papers and forms
we're pulling our money in bribes are
being alleged just business
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's America we all did second chance
[Music]
see Kazak easy
[Applause]
you